the eastern mediterranean is sweltering
under the most intense heatwave
to hit europe so far this year
temperatures across a huge region
from sicily to the balkans and turkey
are already well into the 40s
and the european record of 48 degrees
set in greece
44 years ago could be broken sometime
this week
so what's going on well a high pressure
system that originated in north africa
has been parked over the eastern
mediterranean for several days
it's now created a heat dome with warm
air
trapped by the high pressure above it
all that pressure squashes the air
heating it up even further and with no
clouds and sun-baked earth
it gets hotter by the day it was that
same phenomenon that caused the extreme
heat on the west coast of the us
and canada a few weeks ago climate
change is causing the jet stream in the
northern hemisphere to meander more
as it moves around the world leading to
bigger temperature variations
we've turned the thermostat up so when
these events happen
effectively they're going to happen more
frequently the duration
has more than doubled in some parts of
the world so they last a lot longer
and when they do happen they're much
more intense so we see temperature
records being broken on a much more
frequent basis
the heat and lack of rain are ideal
conditions for
wildfires in the last week huge numbers
have ignited across the region
turkey has so far lost almost 150
000 hectares of forest in 2021 more than
three times the area
would normally lose in a whole year
italy has lost
twice as much as it would normally do
each year so far the wildfires in greece
haven't been any worse than normal but
with
no rain in the forest until the second
half of august at least
that could change